This website that you're seeing on screen has been built by AI end-to-end.
I used Claude Code and Higgs Fields MCP to build this.
I did not write a single line of code. I did not do any 3D modeling.
I did not animate anything frame by frame.
Can you believe it? And the best part is that this process is extremely straightforward.
Anyone can use that to build a cinematic website like this.
So if you want to build a website that not only looks premium but also feels
premium, watch this video till the very end.
I'm going to share the exact prompts that I use for free in the description of this video.
And I bet no video on the internet currently teaches you how to build a cinematic website so easily.
So if you're ready, let's get started. So in this video, we're first going to
set up plot code and connect it to Higgspil's MCP.
After that, I'm going to show you how, in just a few prompts,
you can build this website.
Those prompts are going to be highly customizable. You will be able to change
certain parts of that prompt so that you can adapt it for your use case.
For those of you who are new to this channel, hi, my name is Yashika Jain.
I'm the founder of Automates AI, wherein we're helping businesses automate their
manual processes using AI.
To get more details, check out our agency's website, link in the description.
And on this channel, I cover how AI can be used in the real world, not that hype.
I tell you how you can use it for your own personal work at your job or how
you can sell it to other businesses. So if you are interested,
do not forget to subscribe to the channel. It is free to subscribe.
And thanks to Hicksfield for sponsoring this video. So first things first,
let's set up Claude Code.
Now Claude Code is an AI coding assistant by Claude.
But if you haven't set up Claude code yet, let me quickly show you how you can do that.
But if you already have Claude code set up, maybe you're using it from the terminal,
maybe you've downloaded it, you're using it from the web or from wherever, it's completely fine.
You can follow along. But for the new people, I would recommend the way I am
using Claude code so that it's easier for you and it's not overwhelming for you.
So essentially I use Claude code inside of VS code. So that is the environment
that I prefer because it keeps everything organized for me. So all you have
to do is you have to search for VS Code or Visual Studio Code and download.
It's a code editor and it's free to download. And Cloud Code would be living
inside of Visual Studio Code.
Once you have installed Visual Studio Code, click on Open.
Create a new folder, give it a name, whatever you feel like,
whatever you're comfortable with, and click on Create and then Open.
That is going to open a fresh workspace in front of you so that any code files
that we generate throughout the process, any images videos assets
all of them are organized in this one folder on your system then you simply
have to go to extensions and search for cloud code and then install the verified
one by anthropic this one right here
so either install or enable it after that you'll spot the clouds icon at the top here click on it
cloud code should open up if you're using it for the first time simply sign
into your cloud account now a lot of people ask me in the comments which plan should i use
so Claude code is available in all paid plans by Claude so starting from pro,
all the way to max so in the pro plan you're going to get a little less usage
you might hit session limits and you might have to wait for like five hours
before the session limit resets but in case of max you get enough usage to build
it in one sitting but in case of pro you might have to take multiple settings but again.
It really depends on your budget and if you're okay with this approach or not
so all i had to say was it is available on all paid plans by claude choose whichever
one you want all right so claude code setup do one thing switch the model to,
office better if you can do fable but still let's go with office at least
and then you can either choose the effort level as high or extra high depends on you
extra high is going to take a little more time and a little more tokens
even the high effort level could work let's not go with medium or low because
we're literally designing
scrolling animations so those are the settings we will be on throughout this
video and the next thing we have to do is install the hicks field mcp so here's
what you need to understand we're not building a traditional website
we're building a cinematic website where the product moves here and there, does things.
And for that, we need to generate images and videos using AI.
Claude currently cannot generate AI images or videos.
So what is the solution? The solution is to use the top AI image and video models
like GPD Image 2, Nano Banana Pro,
video models like Seedance 2.5, 2.0 or Clang or Rio 3.1 to generate these scenes for your website.
In my website's case, it could be the scenes where the speaker is moving,
let's say, from one place to the other, or it's revealing itself, etc.
You get the point. And Hicksfield is a platform that gives you access to these leading AI models.
From just one platform, you can access all of them.
So previously, you would have to manually come in here to generate the images
and videos by giving it a prompt and then waiting for the generation to complete.
But thanks to Hicksfield's MCP, you can now connect it directly to your AI assistant.
Maybe Claude, ChatGPD, Claude, Code, Curso, whichever one you prefer.
You simply can connect it to Higgs field. And we are going to do exactly that.
We are going to connect it to Plot Code so that it automatically writes the
prompts, generates the images and videos and saves them for us.
Trust me, it's going to take a lot of headache away from you.
So head over to the first link in the description, which will take you to this page.
Make sure you create an account on Higgs field and top it up with some credits
because generating images and videos.
Consume credits once you're all set come over to Claude code and copy this particular
prompt then here inside Claude code simply paste it
and send it over during this process Claude code is going to ask you to sign
into your Higgs field account
it's going to open up the sign-in page inside your browser so simply sign in
with the account you just now created and then give it the required permissions
and that is how easy it was to connect Claude code to Higgs field via its MCP.
As a bonus, it has also installed skills for Claude code, which is going to
make it even better at these AI generations.
So now simply open up a new chat, switch over to the auto mode.
All right. So now to begin with, we are going to create a cinematic hero shot of our product.
This is going to act as the visual reference for anything that we generate from
now on. So we are basically collecting the assets before we start building the
website. So here's the prompt that I'm going to send. You can find it in the
description with the rest of the prompts.
So I'm asking you to use Hicks field to create the hero product for this project.
We are creating Sonora S1 which is a premium wireless speaker.
Now because this is a hypothetical video for me, I have included the word fictional.
Because I'm literally creating everything from scratch. So make sure you replace
this with your product information.
Also attach your product images with this prompt so that it can use them as references.
So we're asking you to design it as a sculptural luxury object.
Create a cinematic studio product render on a near black background with soft warm rim lighting.
If you want to change this, you can. The product must look distinctive,
generate one product only.
This approved image is going to be the reference for future generations so do
not create any additional versions so i'm going to repeat myself again if you're
building it for a real product please attach the reference images it is going to use those and then
turn it into a cinematic studio product render all right so i hope i'm clear
so i'm going to send this and let's see what we get in the first go
all right so claude code was able to generate an image with hicksfield's mcp.
Very easily it used gpd image 2 and has saved it
to our project so if you click here and then you go to assets you'll find the
image right here that it generated so let's click on it so here's the image
that it has generated again
very realistic even if you're giving your own product images i'm pretty sure
that the image that it generates would match your product but take it to the next level.
All right, beautiful. So we have the name here, a nice texture.
All right. So yes, let's go with this one. If you don't like it,
you can always ask Claude to change things for you. This is going to be our visual reference.
Basically anything and everything we generate from now on is going to depend on this one.
So now let's move forward. We have got the product image and now it is time to generate.
Key scenes for our website. So these will be essentially the visual moments
through which the user is going to scroll.
For example, product in the darkness, product fitting into a particular structure
or product coming out of something. So these are the scenes that we will now be generating.
So here's the prompt that I'm going to send. Again, you can copy it.
So here I'm saying using the approved image use hicks field to create five cinematic
frames and the ratio is going to be 16 is to 9 which is basically.
A rectangle ratio all of these must feel like consecutive moments as if they're
happening one after the other now this is the part where you can get creative
from frame one to frame five you can change this based on your own creativity
the one that i'm going with is that
in the very first frame, I want to reveal the speaker.
So it is going to come out of total darkness. All right. Then the second one is approach.
So the speaker is going to move at a dynamic angle.
The third one is dock. So it's going to fit into a circular structure.
Then there's emerge where the speaker is coming through the other side of the
structure towards the viewer.
I'm not sure if you're able to visualize it, but the last one is then land wherein
it lands into a pristine final hero composition. Then we have some rules here.
No people, no text, no UI, nothing.
Use the same product and generate each frame individually and save them.
So here my approach is more of reveal, move it here, move it there.
If you have some other approach, you can tell Claude, you can replace this whole
part and you can also take the help of ChantGPD or Claude Chat to help you come
up with these scenes basically, the key scenes of your website.
So you will better understand what we're doing here once you see the images that it generates.
So let me send this over. Okay, so it has generated all the five frames.
Let's have a look. So this is frame number one.
Okay, so this is basically emerging from the darkness or we can say reveal.
Then here's another one okay okay then here's the dog okay emerge all right
and land not bad you might not be able to visualize it much because it's quite
static but once these turn into actual motions
it's going to look really nice. So similarly, for your own use case,
generate about five to eight different key scenes and generate them as images first.
So the next prompt that we are going to send here, I think you might have guessed
it, it is converting these images into motions. So generating the videos directly
can degrade the quality and even the concept.
So it's always better to generate the images first and then convert them into
videos or motion and the other thing is during the videos we're also going to
connect two different scenes so the second scene
would be connected to the first one so let me show you the prompt you'll understand
it in a better way so i'm telling it now use the five approved sonora scenes
to create the cinematic motion between them with hicksfield mcp use each scene
pair as the visual start and the end state so.
So create four separate transition clips, not five, because we're pairing them.
Then for each transition, we're giving a short description.
For example, for scene one to two, the speaker slowly rotates and begins moving
through the dark environment towards the circular structure.
So it's going to be a pair between these two. Okay.
Similarly, the instructions for the other transitions. For each transition,
maintain the product. Don't change the product.
No text, no people, no chaos.
Generate each of them separately and save it. Now again, here as well,
you can use your creativity to come up with these transitions.
And you can always take help of ChantGPT or Claude. The last transition is basically
the speaker is moving through the space, it rotates and then settles into the
final hero composition.
And in case you are using ChantGPT or Claude to help you come up with the transitions,
make sure you send my prompt as a reference so that it gets an idea about what
we're doing, about how we're pairing two different scenes.
Okay so yeah let's send it okay so the transitions have been generated so it
used c dance 2.0 which is an amazing model for video generation
as of now and these are the four clips that has generated so let me take a look
let me do this so that you can also see it so this is the very first one,
okay but the part where it comes out of the circle is not quite clear I think,
yeah this one um one can't tell if it's actually coming out of it or not okay
let's check the second one you always have to check things in case you want to give any feedback,
okay so this is going back in,
okay this is perfect then here's another one,
yes this works two and then the last one,
okay now if you noticed all of these are connected so where one stops that is
where the next one starts so we just need to give it feedback on the first one
so i'm simply giving it my feedback and let's see what it says okay so claude has
regenerated our first transition let's take a look.
Okay better but still it's not coming out of the circle but you can still
get a sense that okay it came from there but it's not explicitly coming out
of the circle if you get what i mean okay claude says that this is the way it should be
so appear and then travel toward and then the dock and then pass through it
emerge and settle okay so as per claude this is exactly how it should be for this structure to work.
So no problem, we can move forward with it. So now that we have all the assets
that we need to generate the cinematic website, I think it's finally the time
that we ask Claude to generate the first working draft.
I want to see how these turn out in practice. Basically, when I'm scrolling,
how does it move? How does it feel?
So let's work on that next.
Now, right now, Claude has generic information about how these scrolling animations are done.
But how can I turn Claude into an expert at this?
Basically scrolling animations so that they're clean and they look premium and doesn't look cheap.
A great way to do that is by installing GSAP skills.
So I found this skill on GitHub which basically teaches our AI coding agents how to correctly use.
GSAP, scrolling animations, scrolling triggers, etc, which is exactly what we want.
You can install it. You don't need any third party services, nothing like that.
And this is going to ensure that the scroll driven animations turn out to be clean and premium.
So I'm going to include the link to this GitHub page in the description.
If you want to take Claude a step further, you can install this. I'm going to do that.
So simply copy this one command, head over to Claude, start a new and ask it
to install these skills and then paste what you just now copied
claude will take care of the rest okay and in no time all eight skills have been installed
you know the main one is going to be the scroll trigger which teaches claude
about scroll driven animation skills are a set of instructions
that make claude really good at that particular task and whenever it is doing
anything related to that task, it always refers to those instructions.
Because no matter how good of a prompt we send, if Claw doesn't have the skills
to implement that, it's going to turn out to be horrible.
Okay, so just start a new chat after your skills have been installed.
If you click on this forward slash, you'll be able to spot the skills right here.
Beautiful. So now we're going to send a prompt to Claude, which is going to
convert whatever we have done so far into a website that we can scroll through.
So my starting line is use the installed GSAP skills as your implementation
reference for all scroll and motion behavior.
Then I'm telling it we already have the images and the videos and you need to
build a first working draft of the website using these assets.
So basically Hicksfield has done a great job and now it's Claude Codes job to
turn that into a website.
Then I'm giving it some more instructions.
Then I'm telling it when a user scrolls through the website,
a forward scroll should progress the video, backward should reverse it,
stopping should stop the motion and the video should feel like a part of the
website and not an embedded video player.
One shouldn't even know that okay there's a video on the background.
After that, I'm defining the page flow, wherein I'm also telling it what text to use, etc.
So this is a part that you can be creative about and you can change whatever
you feel like. So for the hero, I'm giving the text and I'm giving some instructions.
Similarly, for each section, I'm giving instructions. For example,
the next section tells the features about this speaker that has 24 hours battery, 360 spatial sound,
so i'm telling it what all we want to include as a part of our website so feel free to change this
however you want then the last one basically reveals the price and gives buttons
to buy it then i'm talking a little bit about the visual direction what to avoid
so that it doesn't look like ai slop
do not make the entire website one pinned video,
okay use normal scrolling between cinematic moments and because this is the
first draft we don't want it to start working on other things like mobile responsiveness etc,
let's wait on that let's first see what we're getting focus on the desktop make
it visually coherent consistent make the scroll work make the typography
field premium make the implementation simple okay so again you can use this
prompt the major thing that you will have to change is the page flow.
Apart from that, you can use whatever I have here. So let me send it through.
And let's wait for the first draft. All right, so it has completed working and
our website is live on this URL.
So let's see what it has built.
I'm quite excited by the way.
Okay let's refresh nice let's scroll,
okay.
Okay nice all right,
Amazing!
Okay.
Is there more?
Beautiful! Let's go through it again. This time I'm gonna scroll a little faster. Okay.
I like this nice this one is my favorite oh my god beautiful,
i like how it goes like this and settles,
beautiful gives that luxury vibe you know that you're purchasing the speaker,
and if you go reverse then that is also working just fine beautiful and let's
check these so sound okay takes you to this section,
let's go to this one okay so it has a perfect mix of cinematography and then
also telling the features of the speaker and,
And these subtle micro interactions.
And then the last one here. Awesome.
To be honest, I don't want to change a thing, but the one thing I noticed is
that it's using M dashes at some places like here. So we're going to get rid of that.
That's the only thing I want to change. So please get rid of the end dashes.
Again, if you have any feedback, just tell Claude.
It's going to fix it for you. You can ask it. You can even regenerate certain
sections, certain scenes. It's completely okay.
And Claude is going to do that for you. I just like how it settles.
Beautiful. I get really excited when the first draft comes out to be nice because
then I know that I don't have to spend another several hours trying to perfect it.
I'm pretty sure you know that feeling okay so let claude do that so while it's
fixing that part here's another thing i want you to do,
so the first round that we generated was for desktop so make sure you also ask
claude to generate it for mobile tablet etc.
And also right click inspect and then click on this icon,
to see how this website is going to look let's say on an iphone 16 pro max
right how this website is going to look on an ipad and if you find something
is off or if you feel that the product is going out of the screen feel free
to regenerate those transitions or those videos
for that particular device okay i'm not going to cover all of that here because
it's going to elongate the video and i'm pretty sure that you know the drill
and you've got the science behind it.
So make sure you make it responsive across different devices.
Make sure that it's smooth and running easily so that for your customers it
doesn't take five seconds to load.
Check it on different devices before you take it live on the internet.
That is my point basically. So do your part before you share it with your customers.
And by the way Claude has removed all the m-dashes. So let's take a quick look.
I wouldn't count this as an m-dash. It's more of a hyphen.
Yeah, it did get rid of them.
And just like that, we built our cinematic website. To be very honest,
this wouldn't have been possible without Higgs Field. This combination between
Higgs Field's MCP and Claude Code is what made all of this possible.
Because you manually generating these videos and images and then coordinating
with Claude Code could have taken you several hours.
But if you just give Claude Kurt access to these AI models through Higgsfield's
MCP, it takes a lot of work off from your plate. So I'll include the link to
Higgsfield in the description, do not forget to use it.
If you found this video valuable and if you were able to learn something new,
do not forget to like this video and do subscribe to the channel for more content like this.
If there's anything else you want me to cover in the future,
feel free to let me know in the comments.
Do not forget to check out the description of this video, you will find the
prompts that i've used right there you can customize the prompts and use it for your own use case,
this could even work for non-product websites you just send these prompts to
chant gpd and it'll help you,
customize them the reason why i'm saying chant gpd for prompt customization
is because i personally feel that it generates better prompts and.
I personally use it the most verse cloud when it comes to prompts if you want
to work with me and my team you'll find the link to our agency's website in the description.
We can help you with external AI implementations that face your customer.
A major example could be customer support and obviously help you automate your internal processes.
You'll also find the link to my paid consulting calendar in the description.
If you want to connect with me personally, you can send me a connection request on LinkedIn.
Do not forget to follow me on X and LinkedIn for some more exclusive content
from my site. So yeah, that is pretty much it for this video.
I will meet you in the next one. Till then, bye!